so the big question is we do some props
on the way out the door
coach doug's next team
who are the options for doug duggerton
in 2019
we don't have the options
yeah we don't yeah
no we have options but we don't know the
options yet i haven't gone to the
coaching carousel yet uh
but i'll throw them out there i've said
these i'd go to lsu i'd go to my alma
mater uh wisconsin i'd probably go back
to usc
i would maybe go back to toledo where i
started this entire journey so there's
there's some options there's some teams
if they become available
they would have there would be no
doubters for me
i don't know how much this tracks with
reality but if west virginia becomes
available um west virginia could be on
there west virginia absolutely could be
on there so it's um
it will be interesting it will be
interesting to say the least we'll see i
i said that i was gonna go to tennessee
to win a national title i did that so it
feels like mission accomplished so i can
i can pack my bags and move on although
i listen if there's no great options i'm
gonna stay at tennessee i'll stay at
tennessee
the next place you go when you get to
the national championship will you blow
it the first time again to build drama
for the second oh my god gosh you hear
you here you go you're you are
mike mike florio pretending that he's
not a twitch commenter he's one of my
favorite
just because i believe it doesn't mean i
have to articulate it on twitch with
poopy stinks yeah you did it you did it
i know i know it's you i know it's you
all right
uh jamal adam's next team these are odds
from late may before yesterday's news
jets were minus 200 we may have to
change those odds cowboys plus 450
texans plus 550 seahawks plus 1200
eagles plus 1400 saints browns bucks
49ers plus 1800 ravens and chiefs
weren't on the board but those are two
of the teams he reportedly is willing to
play for
who do you like out of all those teams
as the next destination for jamal adams
give me give me the cowboys just because
that doesn't feel like a jerry jones
move like i'm just going to it probably
won't even work monetarily
we'll figure it out later let's go all
in let's have no depth let's just have
star players everywhere give me jamal
adams i feel like that's a jerry jones
move
and they can use the possibility of
getting atoms and having to pay adams as
the last push
to get dak prescott to take a team
friendly deal so all the pieces come
together just in time for the july 15
deadline for signing dak press got to a
multi-year contract all right we talked
about christian mccaffrey and a possible
straight-up trade for alvin kamara and
how christian mccaffrey's profile would
elevate although his production would go
down for now he's with the panthers joe
brady the new offensive coordinator said
calling him a running back is an
injustice how about some 2020 totals for
christian mccaffrey courtesy of fanduel
over under combined rushing and
receiving yards
1974.5 what do you got
1974.5 i'll take the over i wha what's
the rest of their offense
and i know you could say you could make
the argument that teams will be able to
key in on christian mccaffrey with no
other weapons out there and uh you know
not like a dynamic offense but i think
chris mccaffrey is one of those guys
that even when you game plan for him he
will get his yards
and they paid him a lot of money well
you're gonna pay him not to use them
that makes no sense so i'd take the over
there i think he'll have another great
year
i think they are going to use him and i
think the panthers i the panthers have
the perfect setup going into a season
now they may stink but the bar is so low
and no one knows what to expect and
everybody's talking about the saints and
the buccaneers and the falcons are
trying to command some attention i kind
of like the idea that the panthers just
kind of swooping uh and lurking and
maybe they can can make some noise if
teddy bridgewater plays like he did last
year mccaffrey plays like he did dj more
as an ascending talent could get
interesting
all right uh
bel we're belmont tomorrow 2 45 p.m
eastern on nbc do you have a pick for
the belmont big cat well the favorite
tis the law seems like a pretty
unbeatable horse so what i'm probably
going to do mike and you don't know any
what i'm saying right now but i'm
probably going to single tis the law and
a pick five
uh and build out my card off of that so
i'll i'll just go explain that because
there are other people out there who
don't know what you're talking about
what does it mean to single tis the law
in a pick five so pick five is there are
you have to you have to win five races
in a row
and uh the more horses that you add to
your card
the higher the prices on the ticket so
if you have four horses in the first
race five horses in the second race
you know three horses in the third race
it goes up and up and up so finding one
horse that you truly believe in to
single so that'll be the only horse i
pick in that race will keep the cost of
my ticket down and let me pick more
horses in the other races
okay i didn't understand any of that but
i'm sure someone else did royal ascot
coming up you asked for picks thank you
very much for that because my email box
has been flooded with picks for you
including money [ __ ]
yeah in the 1350. yeah i like to keep my
money mother earth in the 1350 is your
is your recommendation
i like to give it away you actually said
it during the break you said mother
earth as i was already putting in
because i'd already seen you so thank
you everyone who who uh tweeted me those
pics i'm going to try to take every
single pic i was given which makes no
sense
which makes no sense whatsoever but at
least you'll be able to tell your son
that you made a pick on his first
birthday
and you won
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports